So, my silly little wife is under the impression that um the
police should just let themselves get run over and that federal
agents should >> That's literally not what I said ever.
That's not what I said. And you're strong manning me. I never
got into an accident before, Tim. And Tim drives my car now and
it's a banged up and now it looks like I'm more Mexican than
I am. >> Oh, was it an accident when you ran my motorcycle
over? >> No. And you deserved it.
I do I do think Riot content is good. I do think
I do wonder what Goon's opinion is on this. I would be interested
to hear it actually.
You guys, especially cuz here I I'm like kind of left leading
at this point. And my chat's losing their mind because I'm like,
well, I think there's probably some argument that he was worried
about something when she pulled forward there. So, I need I need
an actual conservative to come on and be like, just tell me that
this guy should have shot more people. Okay, I'm guessing that's
going to be his opinion here. >> Of love.
>> Someone said check out the lab opinion. The ICE agent
will go to jail for homicide. Obviously, good. Still probably
best for people to just let Ice do their original job.
Actually, not the opinion I thought she'd have. Kind of weird
to be honest with you. I do think the opposite. I literally think
he probably should go to jail. I do not think he will.
Yeah, I just I straight up don't think he he will. Pull me in.
Pull me in.
What's happening here? Okay, hold on.
Oh, I'm literally not That's I'm literally not in the Discord.
That's why. Huh?
>> Hey, King.
>> What's up? >> I was actually just getting into
a debate with my husband about this because my husband was like,
"You did nothing. You did nothing wrong. That's the way America
works. He was obviously trying to with the car. >> Tell
him tell him to get in. Tell him to hop on the >> Going
live. You going live? >> Hop in the cord. Hop in the cord.
>> But uh so I so many times we speak and I'm like, "Wow,
I'm giving my children your IQ. That's crazy. That's crazy."
And he said, "You live in a liberal in a liberal world where
you think that violence doesn't happen." And I said, "That's
literally not what I think. I just think obviously he should."
>> Do you want to know what he actually thinks? I can tell
you what he actually
>> Oh, yeah. Sure. Tell me. >> I can tell you what
he actually thinks. He thinks it's like right on the line of
like, "Oh, he he thinks there's like actual nuance here." But
he also knows that the second you give into that nuance that
people will like pick you apart. And so, it's just way easier
to say, "No, he's totally justified in shooting this woman."
That's 100% what he thinks. He probably thinks, "No, no, no,
no, no, no. You don't know my husband. My husband is literally
like he comes from like a QAnon household. Like he doesn't care.
Like he doesn't care about the facts of any system. He doesn't
care about the facts of any
>> He's genuinely
Hi honey. How are you? >> Hi babe. So my silly little wife
is under the impression that um the police should just let themselves
get run over and that federal agents should >> That's literally
not what I said ever. That's not what I said. And you're stannmaning
me. >> I think that should have the ability to run over
the police and
that's exactly my thoughts. >> Hold on. Wait, wait, wait.
Lesbian with three children, by the way. >> Doing more
to populate you than the two of you. Okay. So, >> how does
white kids in America? >> She's putting white kids in America.
All >> Three white kids in America. >> More than
Goon's doing. More than Lab's doing. All right. If you're If
you're trying to fight for the future of the white race, this
woman did more than both of you put together. Okay. >> That's
true. >> That's not my fault. I slowed down I slowed down
on the nicotine. My sperm's good. I did the test. >> Okay.
All right. It is obviously your
>> cuz you stress me out so bad.
>> All right. Whatever. It's fine.
I'm not having that argument on my stream. Okay. Jesus Christ.
But in any case, this woman
not a lesbian. >> Not a not a lesbian. Holy.
>> Yeah. No. I This is my thoughts. And Tim thinks to think
that I live in a dream world. I don't I think that you should
have the right to protest. I also think that if you were impeding
an officer, an ICE agent, you should be arrested. I think you
should be booked. You should go to jail. I don't think you should
be
>> in this scenario. I think it's clear that she was not
trying to run him over. He knew that because when you're that
close to someone and they're driving, you can see them change
the wheel direction as she was because she was doing it furiously
because her wheel turned really quick, which means that he saw
her turn the wheel as fast as she could, which means he saw that
and two of the shots were from her driver's side window when
he was already safe.
>> So, I gave my wife the opportunity earlier. I gave her
a little challenge. I said, "I will get in the car and you can
stand in front of the car with a gun and if you can manage to
get out of the way or >> he shouldn't be in front of a
car." You said You said a smart officer wouldn't be in front
of the car. Correct. >> Yeah. I think he was foolish to
go in front of a vehicle. >> Train to not be in front of
the cars. >> Right. Right. Exactly.
>> I'm not sure where he popped up. I think he was in a
car ahead of them
>> and then he came. >> No, no, no, no, no. He's
on the other side. He's on the other side. Uh, hold on. I just
had that video up. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> This is him.
He's He's right here and they're like walking around and so he
walks around through this side and then he ends up in front of
the vehicle. >> Gotcha. Okay.
>> Yeah. So, he's he's for standing in front of a lesbian
behind the wheel, first of all. >> Right. Right.
>> Second of all, why was the blocking the road? Um, was
she like an ICE protester? One of those >> someone. So,
I got a clip of somebody saying basically somebody there saying
she was leading the the blocking of traffic to impede the ICE
investigation. So, I I got a clip of that. I don't know that
person. They look motan, but I don't know if that's real. I don't
know if that's that's this clip right here. >> This lady
here, we can listen to it really quickly if you guys want to
listen to it. 30 seconds. >> Don't even need to listen
to it. I'm taking one look and I think I've come to my conclusion.
>> Yeah, that makes sense because you're extremely low
IQ. >> You don't need all the
person on your side. say that in the atom. >> You don't
need all of the facts. You don't need to hear from any. You actually
just believe in vibes. You're just whatever the vibe is, you
go with. >> Yeah. I'm a vibes based organism. And I if
I was going to clear something >> and so are and you are
you are literally philosophically black. You are philosophically
black and we're in an interracial relationship
All right. Is that the lady that got >> This is the lady
who got shot. Hold on. This just I need to clear this up for
my chat. This tweet says that her parents said she was not a
part of an ICE protest group, but this on the ground observer
literally said she was she was protesting. Like >> this
person said that woman was at the lead of the protest. So, we
need to figure out what exactly happened here,
>> I I do take the firstirhand account over whatever her
family said about whether or not she was a protester. This is
not going to hold up against the firsthand account of this lady.
>> So, I'm just clearing that up for my chat. Sorry. Were
you guys continuing here? you know, to call each other spiritually
black. >> Do you think, by the way, not philosophically?
You meant >> Do you think that we should be able to
>> Do you think that Americans should be able to protest?
>> Yeah. Violently. That's like the whole idea behind America,
>> right? So, why couldn't she have just ran him over with
the car? >> Uh, she paid the price. >> She should
have She should have actually came with a gun and shot them.
>> Reuben donated $3. >> Or do we not live in a Would
you rather live in a society a white society with order?
Uh, Leah, who maintains that order? It's the people with guns.
>> Yeah. No one is saying I'm not anti-gun.
>> Shooting someone who wasn't trying to kill you. I'm
anti shooting people for no reason. >> A gun and a car
when the car can kill you just as easy as a gun can. >> The
difference is whether or not she was actively trying to kill
him with the car, which she clearly was not in any sense. And
he knew that. I know. In the split second that he had, he should
have >> in the split. No, it wasn't a split second because
look it count how many seconds it takes for her to turn that
wheel. Let's count how many seconds it takes. And he's in front
of her already reaching for the gun as he's trained to >> We'll
go. >> No, he's not. He's not trained to No, he's absolutely
not trained to do that. >> Train to stand in front of the
vehicle. They're not trained to stand in front of the vehicle.
>> Yeah, not in front of the vehicle. His placement was
very bad. He watched He should have He should have played the
corner. He wid swung it and he egoled. Like that's on him. >> And
he's not even a police officer. So he doesn't even have the merit
to detain her. She doesn't have to listen to him. >> Now
hold on, hold on, hold on. >> Yes, he does.
>> So I've heard that that's been getting said on that's
been getting said on Twitter. I do believe there is some like
authority that ICE has that if people are physically obstructing
like their duties, they can do something.
Do they have their permission to take you to prison criminal?
>> No. They have literally they can do a citizen's arrest,
but you do not have to listen. They can ask you for
>> but you can leave.
>> If if you are a citizen, if you have proved that you
are a citizen,
>> but if you're impeding on an ICE officer doing their
job, >> Tim, I don't think, again, Tim, I said this earlier
in the call. If you are impeding an ICE officer, you should be
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I'm snow plowing. They're
getting shot. There's another There's another piece of >> And
you're black. Watch this first part. Watch this first part. Is
it It's going to be difficult. Even if she was impeding earlier,
it's going to be difficult for her to say that they're that she's
impeding now or sorry, sorry, for them to say she's impeding
now cuz she literally tells them to go around her. Listen.
She literally says, "Go around. I'm not trying to block you.
Go around." And cars have already gone by. Right. >> Yeah.
So, they had to have they had to have seen this broad somewhere
blocking them or annoying the out of them. And
>> people for being annoying now. You can just kill people
for being annoying now. >> But unfortunately, she's no
longer obstructing them. >> I don't think I don't think
they're allowed to act. >> Okay. So, I'm going to get my
gun and I'm going to kill you right now
in the house. >> Oh, really? cuz it's literally on my desk.
Come and take it.
Mole on labia.
>> We We all agree on that, right? Everybody in the call,
we agree that she's saying go around. She's not trying to obstruct
them. She let one car go by. She's still letting cars go by.
>> Yeah. But if she's been pestering them all day. Yeah.
Yeah. She's She's definitely not. >> That doesn't matter
if you're pestering all day, honey. Doesn't matter. >> Yes,
it should matter. Like there >> And this is why he will
go to jail. This is why he will go to jail is he committed manslaughter
at the least.
And good and good. >> She committed attempted manslaughter.
>> no, she didn't. You are the dumbest person alive. Alive.
>> If you drive a vehicle at somebody, that's attempted
murder. >> Sorry. Sorry. It's not Hold on. Hold on. Just
to be clear, it's not that she she clearly was turning to go
away from him. She wasn't trying to run him over. It's about
what he thought, right? No, no, no. Hold on. But it's it's about
what he thought in terms of him pulling his gun out.
And my argument and my argument is that he's right in front of
her, can see her extremely clearly, draws his gun before she
even starts to drive,
>> and then he is close enough to where if you can see
her wheel, hold on. That's also wrong. That's also wrong. That's
also wrong. >> Look, look, look, look, look, look. Keep
playing it. Keep playing it. Keep playing it. >> Check
on that one. JST. Okay. >> He's He's draws his gun before
she she even accelerates
evading
vehicle. Watch it again. Draws his gun
while she's back. >> I just had it. I just had it. I just
had it. Watch, Lav. Watch. Okay. Watch your front wheel. Watch
this wheel. Watch this wheel. Watch this wheel >> that
there. It's spinning. He's not even reaching for his gun yet.
Wheel was spinning to move forward. Frontwheel drive. His He's
not even reaching for his gun yet. >> He is reaching for
his gun. Look, you can see he's No, he is literally actively
already reaching for his gun. REACH FORWARD. GO BACK. >> He
has his gun.
He had He had his hand on his gun. He hadn't drawn his weapon.
>> He is going to draw his weapon. That is literally drawing.
Oh my god, guys. Come
>> He is. >> We'll see. >> While she's backing
up to
>> Watch, watch. >> While she's Sorry. Hold on. What
is happening? SO, SHE'S BACKING UP. NO, NO, NO. I'm going to
keep playing it, but we have to agree that she is backing up
in violation of the orders. They They might not have the legal
authority to give these orders. In violation of the orders they're
giving. Get out of the car. Stop the car. Get out of the car.
A guy with a gun gives you an order and you're a lesbian with
no gun, you should probably listen to the orders. >> I
think you should listen to that order and regardless. Yes. I
don't know why she didn't. >> Yeah, she's a and she got
what she deserved cuz she's a [__] >> Oh my
god. >> We're talking about the stupid
>> I think before he draws. So he has his hand on his gun.
Before he draws, I do believe the front wheels spin.
>> Yeah. Which means that And look, he's looking directly
at her. He's looking directly at her this whole time. Look
directly at her while she's turning the >> Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. I need to see. Does he have video here? Hold
on. Did I see him with his phone out? Rec. HE GOT HIS PHONE OUT.
He's shooting a video.
Wait, we need this video. Somebody get me this video.
>> This guy's shooting a Tik Tok in the moment while he's
about to execute this woman. Literally, >> he was so scared.
He was so scared, Tim. He was scared for his life. He was scared
for his life, Tim. >> Doesn't matter if you're scared or
not. >> He's close enough right now. He's watching her.
Watching her. He can obviously clearly see her. Sees that she
is. You can see how fast she has to be turning the wheel for
her wheel to turn as fast as it did. He knows he's not getting
run over. He knows. >> Officers are trained to pull their
gun when a person in a vehicle they're attempting to like detain
is moving the vehicle. That's just standard procedure. >> Then
then why is every single person who's ever been in a car chase
how how come so few of them are shot to in
>> because Oh my god, Leo. >> And he's also not a
trained cop we don't know yet. He's a trained ICE agent.
>> Yeah, he's obviously pretty well trained if he drew
that. >> No, he's obviously not trained because any cop
is going to get discharged for doing this.
I think they should give him. >> He's obviously He's obviously
not that well trained because he's in front of the vehicle like
you said they're not trained to do, right, honey? >> Yeah,
he had bad placement. Things
>> Okay, dude. >> I will say basically
his negligence. Then his negligence Yeah, that's true. His negligence.
Also, that's hilarious because I never got into an accident before
Tim and Tim drives my car now and it's a banged up and now it
looks like I'm more Mexican than I am. Oh, was it an accident
when you ran my motorcycle
>> No. And you deserved it. And I should have [__]
I should have done a twofer. I should have really rammed into
it. >> Yeah. And then I would have shot you
>> Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. >> All right.
So, I think the thing here, female driver, she pulls forward
before her wheels are straightened even and she ends up lunging
the car at him. I think she's fully trying to flee here. Completely
obviously trying to flee. Because she is a woman driver, she
starts pulling forward before her wheels are her wheels are is
still like pointing left, right? Cuz she was backing up. >> The
car is pointed straight at the officer. Like there's no denying
that.
>> Oh my god. >> She backs up. She backs up.
>> Oh my god. To >> the wheel is still pointed towards
the officer to the left when she starts to accelerate. Right
there. She's not even fully straightened yet. You can see the
angle on here. It's She's not even She's straightening. She is
turning. You have, but you have to understand also what that
officer is seeing. He is close enough to see that she is actively
turning the wheel to flee. >> He is watching. >> I'm
guessing that he's looking into the eyes of like a totally terrified
woman who's freaking the [__] out. Yeah.
>> Who is obviously
>> trying to drive away.
>> Yes. While him and his buddies are detaining her >> while
he should not be in front of the car.
And he shoots two shots from her driver's side window.
>> When she's already away. >> Could you go back?
Could you go back just a little bit?
>> Just a tad. Just a hair.
>> Speed this up a little bit. >> Yeah. Let's see
this real slow.
>> You want You want me to slow it down? I'll slow it down.
>> Yeah. Real real slow.
>> All right. They try to open it up. She backs up. Backs
away.
Right.
There she comes to a stop. She's coming to a stop here. She's
starting to straighten. And without straightening, she positioned
the car in his direction. He was not in front of the car. He
was walking that way to get around to the driver's side. She
literally repositioned the car to aim at shoots her twice from
the driver side window, by the way. >> Yeah, because he
got out of the way,
>> Yeah. So, why would he keep shooting
>> Because that's standard procedure. You're not just >> No,
it's not. You pull your gun. >> That's not No, that's not
not when you're already That's when someone is like shooting
a gun at you or has a gun on them. Not is someone who is trying
to flee the scene. You
>> best friends are police officers. They both have said,
"Yeah, that was a position for him to be in, but that was a justified
because if somebody is trying to run you over,
>> if someone's trying to run you over, you have the right
to them." And this happened in a split second. You don't have
time to do anything but defend
>> Oh my god, dude.
>> Whatever. He's going to He's going to jail. He's going
to prison. >> Guys, there's law on this. You're all stupid.
Yeah. Who maintains that law? It's the guy. >> Yeah. This
is This is his thing is that it's all the whole thing's ran on
violence and the and somehow that justifies
somehow that justify even though he will go to prison for
Exactly. Exactly. >> The core tenant of society is upheld
by >> Oh my god. I'm having I'm having a child with this
person. I'm having a child with this person.
>> The only solace I have is that he's never voted and
will never vote. That is the only solace I have. >> Yeah,
cuz voting's gay. What are you going to do when a guy with a
gun shows up? Vote harder. Uh I I vote against you right now.
>> No, Tim, because I would never vote against gun. You
[__] I would never vote against guns.
I don't think that guns are the problem here.
He's trolling.
Screeching howling banshees are the He's literally not. He's
literally not. And now And now we're deferring And now we're
deferring to misogyny as a joke. Misogyny as a >> He was
already doing that. >> It's so I'm so Yeah, of course he's
doing it because he knows how stupid he looks and he knows that
chat's saying that he's stupid and so now he has to be alpha
Chad. >> She said get into arguments. >> She said
I was a Chut earlier. I did not say that. >> And then I
gave her the opportunity to prove her point. I would get in the
car and shoot. >> Yeah. No, he got so angry. He was like,
"You don't get to call me stupid. Why don't we go in the road
and you can have my gun and see if you me?" >> Yes, we
can reenact. Yeah, I know what that means, though. Um I said,
"I'll get in the car. You stand in front of it with my gun and
if you can shoot me before I run you over, you win."
>> She would not take up my offer. >> Because that's
not what happened in this scenario. That's not what my point.
>> Then she bet me um car pay. >> You have to do
my car payment. You have to pay for the rest of my car payment
if he goes to prison. >> Yeah. If he goes to prison, I
have to pay the rest of her car payments. But
if I am right and he doesn't go to prison, then I'm buying Leagues
of Votan Warhammer Army. >> Okay. Well, now it's a joke
to you, but you were almost on the verge of tears 30 minutes
ago and wanted to literally and wanted your echo chamber. You
were trying to go live so that your echo chamber of chuds could
hear you. And now that you're seeing some people calling you
stupid in this chat, you're like, I was only pretending to be
>> into the belly of the beast over here on your turf.
And >> this is not this is not a liberal. >> This
is like centrist. This is like centrist. I'm telling you
a little outnumbered by leftist. >> If you're anywhere
left of me, then you're a libtard. Tim is so low IQ that he doesn't
understand that there is a centrist position. Tim will see Tim
cries if he sees if he hears a bald eagle screech screech and
Leonard Skard playing in the back of a Twitter video. >> Goddamn
right. >> Like there is no he has no idea like he his brain
cannot process nuance. It could he cannot fathom the fact that
I'm a moderate conservative. He thinks the second I say something
like, "Yeah, that guy shouldn't have shot this woman." That I'm
a liberal. that I'm like a bra burning lesbian who like is interracial
and trans and disabled. Like he has no concept of like
any just anything. Just
This is who I'm having a child with. This is who I'm having a
child with.
>> I'm just telling you he probably had nuance and then
he realized being nuanced he'd like lose the arguments and then
that's how conservatives got to this place where they just do
the instead of engaging. >> I'd rather just stomp over
my enemies and their corpses and win. >> Yeah. And that's
black. >> You want to You said that you you love hair.
You want to live in a world that's fascist and and post and postmodern
and where we uh where we uh uh value things like beauty and art,
but you want to live like a black guy.
>> You're going to the camps. >> You're going to
the camps.
>> You're going to the camps. Yeah. You are living by hood
rules. You are black. You are spiritually black.
>> This is the wild west for you. This is I want to live
in a world that's that's
>> Why? So we just have to listen to you screech and howl
this whole time. >> Yeah, that's why I wouldn't have to
screech and howl if my husband wasn't.
And I even said we don't have to argue about this anymore. Put
your money where your mouth is. I can't wait for my car payment
to get paid off. I can't wait. >> This is like blending
into a real argument, which is a little argue a little awkward,
but
>> it's just not clear. We we all understand that it's
just like not clear. I It's clear that the woman shouldn't have
been shot, but it's like the the question isn't whether or not
she should be shot. The question is whether or not the guy has
like some >> self-defense
pretext. Whether he could actually defend himself. >> Yeah.
Your mothering,
>> dude. That's the thing for me. >> Wait, hold on.
Go. Go. Good. You you answer this for me. Could you not see some
like woman driver who you know getting into this exact situation
where she's like getting approached and she freaks out and tries
to drive away. You can't just white women for being bad drivers.
Okay. >> Also, did you see Trump's statement about how
he can't believe that the cop is still alive after being hit
by the >> Why did you just ask a question? Hold on. Why
did you just ask I just asked him a question. Let him ask the
question >> because he's not going to get him for being
bad drivers. That's not a That's not a world we could live in.
I don't like [__] before the word women. Okay, so
let's cut that out. Um, but yes, I I do agree with you. I think
that women drivers are bad and we should um probably decrease
a lot of them. >> I pay our car insurance and our your
premiums are so high because you are as you are and I've never
been in one accident in my life. >> Okay, so she just lied.
By the way, it's on the family business and >> No, it's
not anymore.
Oh yeah, we got taken off because he ran over my dad's motorcycle.
I remember that. That's why. That's why. Gotcha. Okay. Sorry.
Sorry. >> Yeah, that's why. Uh Trump said it's hard to
believe he's alive, but is now recovering in a hospital in a
statement. Did you see the Did Did you see that, honey? That's
your guy. That's your guy. >> Trump said that about the
cop. Trump said that about the cop or >> Yeah. Yeah. About
the cop by a car, man. >> Nope. He didn't. And you want
to see a video of him afterwards? Here, Jess. Okay. I'll send
this to you.
>> There's no way about that. Get the out >> Trump
did say that. Trump did say that. >> That's my president.
>> Yeah, that is your president who you didn't vote for.
Thank >> I think you should do what he did to the Venezuela
guy to uh the governor of Minnesota. I think that'd be funny.
>> Just dealt the team in the middle of the >> Based
on the attached clip, it is hard to believe he is alive, but
is now recovering in the hospital.
>> Yeah, I just sent you a video of what he was doing ex
right after it happened. >> Your country is so cooked.
It's actually >> This is your president.
>> dude. Trump Trump is so funny, man.
Trump is so funny. Yeah, I am Canadian. Love Canada.
>> It's hard to believe he's alive and is now recovering
in hospital. Yeah, we watch this.
>> That's You live You live You want to live in a government
where your president lies to you to save his ass like a black
guy?
>> Trump is our second black president. >> Yeah.
If everybody else is going to be a >> Trump is way more
spiritually black than Obama. That's facts. >> By a million
by one.
>> That's But I'm not using that in a like >> you
live You live in this world. This is the world that you want
to live in. This is the fascism that you say that you want where
your president can just lie to you and the vibes are good.
That's you. You don't want any seen Dune? Have you never read
the Dune books? It's literally all about vibes and lies and how
that becomes real over time through human emotions >> and
that it's up and that it's up. Have you ever read Dune? IT'S
LITERALLY ABOUT HOW BLEAK that is. It's literally about how bleak
that is. Oh my god. You're >> She's She's kind of wrecking
you right now, though. You You just point She's actually kind
of destroying you on this >> Like, holy [__]
>> Yeah, we have to walk the golden path. That's the part
she's about. I I want everyone to know that I'm still with this
man because his his so thick. It's so thick and he me so good
that all of this is worth it. >> All of this is worth it.
>> If you're asking me this how you make up for running
over the motorcycle right now. You just come on and do this propaganda
for him. >> Dude, no, it is. It's big and thick. It's like
seven inches around. >> Are people in chat really saying
that I don't understand the Dune books? What did they watch?
Avatar and root for the gay blue aliens. Oh my god. >> You
guys, you guys need to lock in. If you watched Avatar and you
rooted for the aliens, you're gay.
>> that's the world I want to live in. >> I'm sorry.
I I think the line actually is if you watch Avatar, you're gay.
>> I'm sorry. I think >> you watch Avatar, you're
just gay. You're watching Hollywood fantasy. There's something
wrong with you.
>> I don't think even watched it. I don't even think he
watched it. >> This is what I mean. It's all about he just
will say things that he like
he has heard other people say. >> It's fun.
>> Okay. I am
15% is going to do a lot of caring for our children. >> You
you understand that he's literally just doing that when he loses
the argument to annoy you, right? Cuz then >> not
No, he's not doing it to annoy me. He's not doing it to annoy
me.
>> I'm telling you this is what he this is what our actual
fights become. is him gish galloping about something else that's
not related and him never backing down because he needs to be
right even if he's wrong. >> You don't need evidence when
you just feel right. Like >> this is why men are the more
emotional.
That's why. >> Yeah.
Screeching banshee in my ear is not the more emotional one. You're
>> What? You win because you're you're you're more measured
in this conversation. You've been on your knees crying in front
of me. So shut the [__] up. Yeah, I know what I know
what your I know what your face looks like when you
>> wildly flailing back and forth between a real argument
and then like, "Oh, I'm sorry. I'll say something nice now."
Back and forth. It's very funny. Just fun to observe. Okay. Do
you guys do this on your stream? This is fun. >> Yeah.
Tim literally be like Tim literally be like, "Feelings don't
care about your facts."
>> That's a Tim. That's Tim's model. >> No vibes.
>> That's all That's all conservatives are like that now.
>> That's not all conservatives. That's all his type of
conservative. Yeah, >> that's literally anybody who would
vote for Trump is like that. Yeah, 100%. >> Do you think
the Germans cared so much about the facts? Like, oh wow, 12%
of are responsible for all the >> No, hold on. You don't
get to compare yourselves to the Germans. You aren't the at least
cared about his people. Trump is just stealing from you guys.
You're losers in America. If you were at least that could be
like, well, you're getting something out of it, but actually
you guys are like in foreign countries and then domestically
you're like libertarians. Oh, give it all the billionaires. Let
let Peter Teal have all of her money. It's racial This is what
racial integration has done.
other countries and steal their bully other world leaders. >> But but
but your your people should benefit from that. And they actually
don't benefit from that at all. It's just going to
gay liberal Peter Teal gets all of your money for being the best
grifter. Literally a gay liberal makes all of the money from
conservatives getting like totally
totally propagandized. I it's
offer all your money up to a gay liberal who has the surveillance
set up.
>> You need to unban Ben Thorp from Goom Squad. Good. >> Oh,
my night gets even better. >> Yeah. So that he can participate
in the EA. Speaking of the EA is happening in about 5 minutes,
guys, on >> It's actually happening in an hour. I moved
it back an hour. >> No, you didn't because we already slated
for the EAgirl. Tim, you can't do that to her time.
You guys ARE DOING AN E TOLD YOU TO GO LIVE WHICH is why I already
told you
just cover the politics. The politics is way better. >> What
are you talking about? >> Oh my god. No, it's not. You
can only go over this for so long because it's vibes based for
him. He doesn't care about the facts. Why does he even have to
watch
>> I'm trying to get my go over it forever.
>> I'm going to try to get my audience some. You can enjoy
your little political circle, >> dude. Yeah, for the Oh
my god. >> Your audience is getting 100%.
>> Definitely happening. >> Definitely. at least
three people from my Eates who have directly gotten laid.
>> Don't believe it.
Proof.
>> I'll give you names. I'll give you VODs. >> You
could give me names. You could give me names. I'm going to need
videos cuz I don't believe you.
>> All right. Ben Thorp won the Grace Thorp eate. Um, not
sure if we can record >> That's cheating. That's cheating
and obviously true. Okay. >> But let's be honest, Ben Thorp
was cracking that before he went on your E date. So, okay. That's
>> These things happen.
>> Yeah. Okay. >> Oh my god. >> All right.
In conclusion, I wish I was there. I would have handled things
differently and uh there'd probably be a lot more people dead.
So, >> I've just tipped $5. Actually, don't.
>> Leah. I love you. >> I love you, too. >> JSTLK.
Nice to meet you. >> Thank you guys for coming on.
>> We talked many times, but >> I'm gonna hang out
here for a second while you start your stream, honey. All right,
>> go do your job. Go make money to pay for my car payment.
>> Go do like anything ever at all. >> I literally
do more than you every single day. You are the most annoying
person in the world. >> I just cleaned your house. >> I
cook all of your meals. I just worked a full 40hour week and
I'm going to go to school full-time. [__] Literally
you. I don't want to talk to you anymore. Leave. Bye.
>> No, you can't kick me out. I'm actually >> No.
Go. No. Yeah. Yeah. Go have fun. I was going to leave anyways,
but now I'm gonna leave. Yeah. >> No, no. Just stay. Just
stay. Put off the start of your stream and stay here. Obviously,
that's a good idea. >> No, he obviously needs to get out
>> Keep telling him no, Lav. Keep telling him no so he
stays.
>> No, I'm not going. >> Honey, you should stay.
>> All right, I'm out. >> Honey, please stay. >> No,
I I got to go. >> No, you got to stay. >> No, I'm
leaving.
>> What a great time.
That's uh
>> I [__] hate that guy >> just in here.
Okay. All right, bro.
>> Holy [__] My cortisol levels are so
>> I Dude, I want to I I like those conversations. They're
fun. But Jesus Christ, you guys are like actually fighting in
the middle of it. Makes me feel very awkward. I don't want to
farm like the end of your relationship or something. Feels up.
>> Oh my god. You think that's the end of a relationship,
dude? The [__] cops have been called. things are
not. This is nothing. This is nothing.
>> Okay. All right. >> This is This is literally
nothing. I've gone to the psych ward. Like, this is This is a
regular
That's us being sweet to each other.
>> Wow. Yeah. I I've never heard any of those details.
So, it sounded like you were litigating details on my stream,
which was just awkward. Okay. A little awkward, that's all. >> It's
not awkward. Grow up, dude. >> Very fun. Very fun. >> Your
parents loved each other growing
>> My parents were divorced. No, they didn't love each
other. Well, >> that's probably that's probably why you
never saw a fight like that. If they really loved each other,
they would have fought like that. >> O
Jesus Christ. >> This girl sounds fat. Oh, he's being
>> damn. You might you might have to cam up now. That might
be no choice.
>> I'm just saying.
All right. Where were we on this? I think we watched we finished
the press conference. Or did we finish the press conference?
We didn't finish the press conference. Let's watch just a little
bit more here and then we're going to move on. We've got the
Asmin take from today. We'll cover some of that. The tweets that
were going around. All right. Asmin go very much on the cop side.
A lot of people very much not on the cop side.
We'll see how it goes. Finally,
you know, we've got a lot of work that needs to happen right
now to make sure that first of course the scene was secured as
much as possible that we were >> I will say I can't believe
that guy said many of my viewers have gotten laid on the E dates
and he's like well Ben Thorp won an eate with Grace. It's like
dude that's cheating. That's obviously not. You're just lying.
>> He is so annoying the most annoying person in the world.
>> Get the victim now deceased to the hospital. So, we've
got a lot of work to do in the coming days. >> Watching
the uh the Jacob press confer
I'm so skinny. I'm so skinny. I'm the skinniest woman in the
world.
>> Rad. Thank you for the gifted sub. That's another hour
on the stream, guys. Let's go. 245 35. >> My new camera
kind of [__] sucks though.
Oh, you are setting up cam. Hold on. Let me go pop this thing
out to show.
>> Oh my god, I just came from the gym. I look like
>> Oh my god, I actually look like >> What in the
world?
No, it's fine. It's fine.
Wait, what is this? Why is this not There we go. Dude, my OBS
like totally broke with how it does the
the like resizing of windows. I hate it. I hate it being like
this, but I do about it.
>> Wow. Okay. Thank you. >> Don't know. Uh that
>> did you tell her I said Lavatar? I did not. Ribbon Ruben,
she doesn't know that. She doesn't know you said that. >> I
thought it was funny. >> Oh, well, she did hear that. She
thought it was funny. >> You're funny. Ribbon Ruben. We're
prepared to do >> away. Get away. Get away. >> Among
them is our chief. Camera's falling down. Just say no. >> Oh
my god. Everyone in this house. Every single being in this house
seeks to destroy me. >> My name is Brian O'Hara. B.
>> I am a working mom.
>> Patient going by. I just came home from the gym. Dude,
it was leg day. I sweat a lot. It was hard.
>> So hard. What a tough life.
>> It's not a tough life. It's why I look like sweating.
>> I think I mean technically the camera's really small.
Did you just vape on my stream? That's just Dude, that that's
actually worse than anything else you've talked about. Jesus
Christ.
>> It looks You literally look the same as you always do.
What do you mean you look like you look the exact same? >> Well,
it's just my my hair.
Yeah, you have a bandana on. Oh, what the what was the sizing
of the window?
Is that what's going on here? Is this window like somehow
this window somehow is like free transform? How do I stop that?
Don't like that at all.
How to fix that in OBS. Oh well,
I'll figure it out later. >> Doesn't matter. I'll deem
you. Okay. >> Minneapolis police officers received a report
of federal law enforcement being involved in a deadly force incident,
meaning shots had been fired. Minneapolis police officers responded
to the scene. >> Is there a make? >> He arrived and
found >> wake up. Okay, fine. I'll wake up. >> Gunshot
wound to the head.
Life-saving measures were performed at the scene in >> Should
I be blonde or brunette?
>> Wound to the head. Life-saving measures were performed
at the
>> dude. No way. Hold on. She got the gun cocked.
I need to I need this. Okay.
Wait. I need to put this in the Discord. Oh, hold on,
dude. No way.
this sign language person is going off the whole time. Dude,
wait. I didn't see the the mayor's looking at >> a gunshot
wound to the head. Life-saving measures were performed at the
scene.
Including CPR.
The woman was transported to Henipin County Medical Center where
she has since been pronounced deceased.
The prelim pre preliminary information that we have indicates
that this woman was in her vehicle uh and was blocking the roadway.
>> Dude, is this like is this going to be another situation
where the person who's doing sign language literally doesn't
know how to do sign language? They're just pretending.
I feel like I don't know cuz I I can't do is it ASL? I can't
do it. Yeah. Yeah. It feels like it's somebody who can't do sign
language who's doing it. >> On Courtland Avenue, midway
between 33rd Street and 34th Street in the city.
At some point, a federal law enforcement officer approached her.
>> You allowed Put on a wig. Dude, I literally had >> began
to drive headband on.
>> Relax. No, I'm not. >> Two shots were fired. >> Uh,
the vehicle then crashed on the side of the roadway.
>> Minneapolis police officers secured the crime scene.
My hair is just yucky covered in sweat right now. >> Trying
to preserve the evidence that is there. We have since turned
over the scene both to the Federal Bureau. Had >> a really
hard workout today >> as well as the >> Oh god. >> Do
you guys want to see my gains? Do you guys want to see my glute
gains? >> Jesus Christ.
>> Oh, the FBI is involved. This is going to be a joke.
>> Means he will go to prison.
>> Um, who knows? No, no. Cash is not >> Well, now
it's political.
>> Well, now it's political. >> Cash is going to
this up. Cash going to it up. >> Minnesota Bureau of Criminal
Apprehension, which will be conducting an investigation into
this use of deadly force. Um, >> great. We are spiritually
black and
>> City Council President, uh, other members of the city
council, state
>> Trump has already pre-pardoned him on Twitter. Was this
here? Was he saying he was going to pardon him?
Uh, I just viewed the the clip of the event which took place
in Minnesota, Minneapolis, Minnesota. It is horrible thing. It
is a horrible thing to watch. The woman screaming was obviously
a professional agitator and the woman driving the car was very
disorderly obstructing and resisting who then violently, willfully,
and viciously ran over the ICE officer who seems to have shot
her in self-defense. Based on the attached clip, it's hard to
believe he is alive, but is now recovering in hospital. The situation
is being studied in its entirety. But the reason these incidents
are happening is because the radical left is threatening threatening,
assaulting, and targeting our law enforcement officers and ICE
agents on a daily basis. They're just trying to do the job of
making America safe. We need to stand by and protect our law
enforcement officers from this radical left movement of violence
and hate.
I guess Lav left. Put this off for now. I don't know if she'll
be back or not.
I do like that this is the only clip he throws up though.
>> Yeah, this is this is some like wild actually. This
is totally wild.
Um well, I think Gunnar was here. >> Not a just tipped
$5. Wow. And this is the same lav that sh on my looks every time
she's on this fat obese couch sitter stream.
WOW. What the? But thank you for the donation. I think Gunnar
Gunnar's audience was